I'm Victor M Sweeney licensed funeral
director and I'm here today to answer
questions from Twitter this is burial
support
[Music]
[Applause]
z1b21 why are the different shapes of
caskets typically in the United States
when we're talking about a receptacle to
bury a dead body we talk about a casket
a casket is rectangular oftentimes in
other parts of the world you're going to
see what's called a coffin so a coffin
is what we might call anthropoid shape
narrower at the top where the head is
wider at the shoulders and then narrow
down at the feet other countries around
the world tend to use coffins and we use
the term even colloquially here in the
United States so when you hear someone
talk about Grandma's in the coffin odds
are good she's in a rectangular casket
lamia 233 can you spread ashes anywhere
or are there legal restrictions on that
this is such a good question and it's
one I'm asked all the time typically a
state does not really have a vested
interest on what you do with human
cremated remains so you could scatter
them essentially anywhere you like in my
state a family has visitation rights
where a person is scattered so if you
scatter grandma in the bed of her garden
you end up with visitation rights to
that flower bed in perpetuity you can
also do other things with cremated
remains you can have them made into
jewelry you can buy a small Keepsake
urns I've heard that you can press them
into records there are all sorts of
things that you can do with cremated
domains because they are simply
pulverized bone dust and they're inert
carbons everything that is organic in
them is gone it's not going to feed a
tree as people commonly like to think
but you can do with them mostly whatever
you wish here's a question from Plucky
duckling our funeral pyres and Viking
funerals a thing anymore there is one
place Crest Stone in Colorado that does
allow a funeral pyre so that does exist
but you have to live in a very specific
Locale a funeral pyre as we're thinking
of it here is usually a large pile of
wood or other flammable material that a
body is set on top of and then the whole
thing is set a light as far as Viking
funerals this is kind of a misnomer
you're probably thinking of putting your
loved one in a boat with their hands on
the pommel of their sword and pushing
them out into the lake shooting flaming
arrows at it until it goes up in Flames
Viking funerals actually weren't like
that they were buried with their sword
in boats and all sorts of grave Goods
but the boat was dragged on land and
buried intact here's a question from
signature why do people take photos of
the Dead in a casket at funerals and
post it on social media please stop
doing that interesting thing in most
places the right to take a picture of
the deceased falls to the family so they
can either allow it or disallow it but I
agree don't put it on social media
that's something that should be kept
just for your own personal use next up
we have a question from Stan comb Wills
who gets to decide who gets invited to
my funeral the short answer is your
family they can decide who will come and
likewise who is not allowed there fun
fact you do not need an invitation to
attend a funeral you can just show up
funeral crashing is a thing there was a
gal That I Used to Know back in one one
of the funeral homes I worked with her
first name was Bunny and Bunny would
come to every funeral regardless of
denomination and location and I am
certain she didn't know that many people
she came for those sweet sweet scalloped
potatoes and ham our next question is
from Nate bones how come cemeteries
never run out of space sometimes
cemeteries do run out of space in larger
metropolitan areas sometimes it's the
case where families will actually bury
their loved ones on top of existing
graves in certain other countries and in
other parts of the world you actually
just rent a grave space so for instance
in Germany Your Grave space is not your
moms or dads forever but for a period of
years after which your rent expires they
dig up the dead and they put them
elsewhere in a common grave usually
here's a question from Dr bum for fire
what is sky burial sky burial is a
practice that takes place in Tibet or
Nepal where bodies are actually left out
and hacked apart for condors and
vultures to eat the the way that they
render a human body to just bones is by
letting animals do the work we have a
question here from teaspoon do funeral
homes have busy times of the year or is
it just dead all year fall and spring
are going to be the busier times of year
fall because the weather change has
something to do with there being more
deaths and spring is usually busier
especially where I'm from where it's
cold we have a normal workload and then
all sorts of burials that we had to
delay over winter that end stretch of
winter into spring when everything
starts to melt the ground is simply too
soggy to even set foot in the cemetery
let alone bring a whole line of cars in
a casket from Kai schwa why are funeral
homes always family owned interestingly
enough more and more we're seeing
funeral homes get bought up by corporate
entities so it could be that your local
Funeral Home despite being called The
Smith Family Funeral Home is actually
owned by a larger conglomerate who might
operate five six ten funeral homes in
your area I think you'll always find
that the the business where you know the
owner and they live in your locality and
they shop at your stores are generally
going to be more caring and more
transparent than the ones that are there
simply to turn a profit from Harvey 180.
so I'm completing my organ donation form
you can literally donate everything
including skin bones and tendons so how
do funerals work because there will be
nothing to put in the Box most organ
donation companies those procurers they
don't take everything they'll take the
femur they'll take some of the muscle
they might even skin the whole thing so
it looks like one big nasty roast beef
but then they also will provide us with
a large wooden dowel that's the exact
shape of the femur so we can kind of
rebuild the shape of the leg from Amy
Bell how do you talk to your children
about death would love to hear from
parents who have tackled this tough
topic probably my best piece of advice
for parents when they talk to kids about
death is don't say it's like Grandpa
fell asleep I think little kid kids can
conflate the two I would say be honest
with children about death tell them in
reality that that someone is no longer
living kids typically I think have a
better handle on death and really
especially Elementary school-aged
children I think they have a want to be
involved when they come to a funeral
there are so many times where I see
families come and they kind of Shuffle
the kids off somewhere else and say that
death is for adults but really death
affects every single one of us here's a
question from curl girl 62. what is a
green burial so there are a lot of
things on the green spectrum that we can
do with funerals it could be something
like we bury the body without a casket
and without a vault straight in the
ground it could cover something like
having we call resumation or
decomposition instead of cremation it
could be something like using a wooden
casket instead of metal or even using
what they call Eco embalming fluids so
embalming fluids made out of methyl
alcohols instead of carcinogens like
formaldehyde all right here's a really
good question from caterade it is 2 cold
to go for a walk so I went to the
mausoleum as one does why anyone would
want to spend eternity in a safe deposit
box is beyond me one distinction to make
Mausoleum generally refers to a large
building that Houses full caskets above
the ground another thing that looks
similar to a mausoleum is what we might
call a column barium these are typically
stand-alone structures above the ground
that have shelves or what we call niches
to place urns so mausoleums are for
caskets and column barrier are for urns
oftentimes when I talk to families that
have entombments rather than burials in
the ground usually their primary concern
is water if you're along a body of water
like a lake or river maybe spending
eternity in a wet cooler is worse than
spending it in a safety deposit box next
we have a question from brain rot batty
had to break up a fight at the funeral
home today why y'all swinging on each
other I have had to break up a couple
fights at funerals or go into dad mode
and scold some people it's a highly
emotional situation sometimes there are
a lot of unresolved issues between the
deceased and their family or maybe other
members of the family talk about
inheritance those things can be a mess
our next question is from Bob White our
funeral expenses tax deductible the
short answer to that is no here's a
question from SJ durowski why are Irish
wakes always so loud and popular it's
actually one of those things that led me
into funeral service in a way I'm from
an Irish family and we're very proud of
it but when my grandma Sweeney died my
cousins smuggled in a whole bunch of
coolers of booze into the funeral home
and uh all the older ones proceeded to
get absolutely wild but seeing people
have fun at a funeral and kind of
Embrace Life at a funeral was one of
those things where I saw it as a young
man and realized that a funeral doesn't
have to be entirely dour from our friend
GB so really there are professional
mourners people getting hired to cry at
funerals that does exist in some
cultures and it does exist right here in
the United States in some places some
cultures put a premium on outward
Expressions showing how much we loved
the dead in Ireland for instance they
have what are called keeners so it's a
particular type of musical lilting whale
I don't know if I'd want to hire
professional mourners for my own funeral
I would kind of like the idea that
people can show their emotions I think
that is a very good thing and maybe it's
the case that having those professional
mortars kind of move those sorts of
emotions forward here's a question from
M why is Extreme embalming a thing
please make it stop I kind of agree with
you it is wild for those of you that
don't know what extreme embalming is
typically that's referring to Preparing
a body in a life-like vignette so if
he's a boxer you have the gentleman
propped up in the corner of a boxing
ring or if your cousin is a gamer we
have her in a gamer chair holding an
Xbox controller if someone asked me I I
could do it it would take an awful lot
of Ingenuity but I kind of agree Make It
Stop here's a question from powerslave
why do funeral homes look so creepy they
should have a tropical Cabana vibe that
would make funerals a lot less drab I
think the primary reason is oftentimes
they're very old establishments so
they've been in a community for a very
long time you might hear the term
Funeral Parlor when funerals moved out
of a person's home held in their parlor
and into somebody's business setting
where everybody could gather and pay
their respects so when you have the the
prerequisite of being a parlor you do
tend to have 19th century accoutrements
like big drapes and overstuffed chairs
and maybe some of those haunted
mansion-esque things that you might
think are creepy here's a question from
pal do morticians need to take a mental
health and stability examination to get
their certificate and do you have free
access to therapy we do not have to take
a mental health and stability exam I do
think something like that would actually
be helpful in the future for people in
my position I also do not have free
access to therapy when you work around a
great deal of death you learn to kind of
handle death and I say handle it because
I've never really actively coped being
that it's it's so ever present in my in
my daily life it's a part of life that
I'm really comfortable with so in the
same way you probably don't see OB
nurses going through existential crises
when babies are born I'm not going
through existential crises when somebody
dies one in one out and I'm just here to
help serve you guys load Jose mo why do
people plan funerals before someone dies
hashtag Grandma's still kicking I would
say we're seeing more and more people
pre-plan their funerals simply for the
reason that people want things done the
way that they want it the best thing a
person could probably do short of
talking to your local funeral home and
doing formal planning would be to write
down what you want at least the basics
whether it's cremation or burial or
maybe a mix between the two write that
down somewhere and make sure your loved
ones have it from Carly Starr 82 why are
funerals so expensive feels like a scam
usually when we're planning a funeral
there may be three subsections that a
family has to pay for the first one is
Professional Services that would include
things like setting up the funeral and
going to it and bringing a body from the
place of death maybe embalming the body
or taking the body to the Crematory
another subsection would be merchandise
things like a casket or an urn maybe a
burial and then the third section are
what we call cash advanced items so
things like you're a Gravedigger your
funeral lunch flowers newspaper
obituaries all the other odds and ends
that are tangentially related to the
funeral will get conglomerated into one
big bill so usually when a family
receives let's say a ten thousand dollar
funeral bill it will include part that
goes to the funeral home but a lot of
it's going to be paid out to everybody
else that participates to make the thing
possible our next question is from SOS
Fitness do funeral homes charge extra
for plus size coffins the answer
is yes being that there are more
materials that go into a plus size or
what we call an oversized casket or
coffin means the price goes up here's a
question from tyranny one he's wearing
black to funerals still a thing or can I
wear any neutral color you can wear any
color you want I've had families where
they want the funeral to be more of a
celebration I've had families come
wearing all Hawaiian shirts or all
sports jerseys or everybody wears purple
because that's Grandma's favorite color
next up we have a question from sabru
attic how to write a eulogy I'm not good
with words I actually had to give the
eulogy at my best friend's funeral when
he took his own life and that's an
extremely challenging thing my goal with
that was to talk about my friend's life
but then talk about kind of those
Universal values that we all share so
things like unconditional love and what
he taught me about patience those are
all universals that I think we can all
understand and those are really really
good topics for eulogy here's a question
from Return of the goth is it a southern
thing to pull over out of respect for
the dead for a funeral procession or do
you all who are elsewhere do it too it
is always confused and irritated me
they're dead I don't know them I'm on my
lunch break move it it really depends on
where you live in the country where I
grew up in the state of Michigan it was
very customary when you saw a hearse go
by you pull over and let them through
where I live now that's not usually the
case in fact I've been in trouble often
enough for driving the Hearst down the
very middle of the road on the dotted
yellow line to get people to pull over
only because I have a place to go too
and typically it's a little more time
sensitive than your lunch break maybe
instead of being irritated you could
think of it as a a gift you could give
to the family of your time it's usually
only a little bit why would you have a
luncheon for a funeral anyway hashtag
doesn't make any sense there is
something really nice about getting
together after the fact when the work is
done to just sit and relax and and fill
our bellies I think inside all of us
there is this certain caveman aspect we
bury our dead and we put them away for a
time and then we also gather together
and eat and drink and make Marion I
found that having that opportunity to
gather and to eat and to drink and to
share is really really valuable and
that's all the questions I hope you
learned something until next time
[Music]